ries et 11 décès 3 en martinique cette
en guadeloupe 1 à mayotte
petit focus sur mayotte qui comme vous
le savez est un département isolé sans
un cas confirmé 11 patients hospitalisés
deux en réanimation
dix patients sont guéris et un décès
malheureusement est à déplorer et 650
tests ont déjà été réalisés sur ce
département nous avons ce soir 6017
patients en situation grave qui
nécessite des soins lourds de
réanimation 6017 personnes qui
nécessitent une surveillance constante
c'est plus que la capacité initiale de
la france en réanimation qui étaient
autour de 5000 personnes prises en
charge en réel en réanimation et donc
vous voyez
non seulement les forts des
établissements de santé pour créer des
places en réanimation mais surtout ce
que ce qu'implique cette épidémie en
termes d'impact pour les patients
les formes graves sont vus chez des
adultes 34% de des patients ont moins de
60 ans 60 % ont entre 60 et 80 ans et 80
personnes sont actuellement
hospitalisées en réanimation
âgés de moins de 30 ans aujourd'hui 450
deux patients de plus ont été pris en
charge par les services de réanimation
c'était 458 hier depuis le 1er mars 4032
décès ont été observés en milieu
hospitalier
c'est 509 de plus aujourd'hui 83 % de
ces décès ont lieu chez des personnes de
plus de 70 ans
enfin et c'est important de le dire dix
mille neuf cent trente cinq personnes
sont sortis guéris de l'hôpital
depuis cette même date du 1er mars et
notamment 1491 personnes sont sorties au
cours des dernières 24 heures geri de
l'hôpital je vous rappelle que les
milliers de personnes qui sont confinés
à domicile malades guérissent au bout de
quelques jours et qu'il faudrait
effectivement ajouter toutes ces
personnes guéries qui n'ont pas consulté
en milieu hospitalier
en ce qui concerne la situation dans les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
vous savez que nous mettons en place un
dispositif de signalement ce dispositif
de signalement se met en place
progressivement depuis le 28 mars ils
montent en charge pour couvrir
l'ensemble des structures d'hébergement
social et médico social
elles sont très nombreuses en france
afin de vous fournir un point consolidé
hebdomadaire est donné commence à
remonter ne sont pas totalement
consolidé nous avons déjà plusieurs
milliers d'établissements qui commencent
à remplir des éléments sur des cas
possibles ou des cas confirmés sur des
décès survenus dans l'établissement ou
survenus à l'hôpital et j'espère pouvoir
donner ces chiffres consolidés des
demandes en ce qui concerne la
surveillance syndromique dit en
population
les services d'urgence ont renseigné
3745 passage aux urgences hier soit 19 %
de leur activité totale nous observons
38% d'hospitalisation après passage aux
urgences et 4 % directement en
réanimation
elle souhaite médecins à hyères signalé
1328 intervention pour suspicion de kovy
de 19 au cours de la journée soit 22 %
de l'activité totale
enfin les laboratoires de ville ont
réalisé 32 mille tests dont 9630 positif
soit 30% de positivité ces fameux tests
pcr comme vous le savez sont faits
depuis le début pour confirmer un
certains nombre de diagnostics
nous en avons désormais 56 1989 en
france au sujet de ces tests de vous
savez nous montons là aussi en puissance
en terme de capacité exemple qu'au cours
des dernières des derniers jours nous
soyons aux alentours de 20 mille tests
quotidiens
un point important la surveillance aussi
de la mortalité toutes causes confondues
à l'échelon national l'excès de décès
par rapport à la mortalité attendue à un
mois de mars atteint 13% en semaine 12
et devient aussi significatif avec une
hausse de 7 % en semaine 13 celle du 23
au 28 mars
à l'échelon régional un excès de
mortalité en semaine 12 est signifiée
dans plusieurs région grand-est
bourgogne franche-comté ile-de-france au
de france et corse et on commence à voir
aussi se dessiner en semaine 13 un excès
de mortalité dans les régions grand test
bourgogne franche-comté ile-de-france et
auvergne rhône-alpes à l'échelon
départemental
22 départements dont 17 sont situés dans
les cinq régions les plus touchées
présentent des excès de mortalité par
rapport à la mortalité attendue sur la
semaine 12
hélas cela concerne des personnes de
plus de 65 ans et en semaine 13 nous
avons le même signal pour 20
départements qui présente déjà les excès
de mortalité chez les personnes de plus
de 65 ans vous savez que cette mortalité
est enregistrée par l'état civil et
qu'il y a toujours un petit retard dans
la déclaration en mairie puis dans la
déclaration de l'état civil à l'insee et
à santé publique france depuis le
premier jour notre objectif a toujours
été d'offrir les meilleurs soins à
chaque patient est évidemment notamment
aux patients les plus graves qui
nécessitent une prise en charge en
réanimation
cela nous a conduits au nom de la
solidarité nationale a opéré de nombreux
transferts de patients des régions les
plus en tension vers les régions les
plus épargnées par l'épidémie vous
pouvez voir sur la carte derrière moi
l'ensemble des opérations qui ont été
menées je vous rappelle que le 18 mars
nous avons effectué un premier transfert
de six patients de réanimation par une
opération aérienne militaire dit mort
fait depuis quatre opérations militaires
ont eu lieu au départ de la région grand
est
la dernière s'est terminée avec succès
hier
aujourd'hui deux tgv médicalisé 30
transportant 36 patients graves d'île de
france sont bien arrivés à destination
en bretagne où ils poursuivront leurs
soins dans les meilleures conditions
au nom de la solidarité nationale et
européenne des transferts
transfrontaliers à destination du
luxembourg de la suisse de l'autriche de
l'allemagne ont été réalisés ou sont
encore en cours pour cent quarante deux
patients graves de la région grand est
quatre opérations de transfert sont
également en cours pour déplacer des
patients d'ile-de-france et des patients
du grand test vers les régions pays de
loire centre val de loire et occitanie
par voies aériennes et terrestres
c'est une opération totalement inédite
vous l'avez probablement vu les images
sont impressionnantes ce sont des
patients qui nécessitent une
surveillance constante qui nécessitent
un accompagnement médicalisé qui
nécessitent des équipements
respiratoires des seringue électrique
des perfusions donc c'est à chaque fois
très compliqué à organiser
et c'est une opération magnifique de
solidarité avec des soignants mobiliser
pour que tous ces transferts se passe
dans les meilleures conditions qu'elles
se passent par voie aérienne par watt
terex par voie ferroviaire par
hélicoptère ou par voie routière
d'autres opérations sont prévues pour
soulager encore nos hôpitaux et surtout
nos équipes soignantes
je peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
de nouvelles opérations de type morphée
évacuation aérienne militaire et tgv
médicalisés sont planifiés pour soulager
notamment le grand test
grâce à la mobilisation totale de
l'ensemble des moyens de l'état
nous comptabilisons aujourd'hui 344
patients lourds dans un état critique
transférés vers des régions - en tension
ce nombre est amené à progresser dans
les jours et les semaines qui suivent
toujours dans l'optique de soutenir
l'effort des régions les plus en tension
nous procédons à un renfort en
ressources humaines je vous ai déjà dit
c'est important pour accompagner des
patients en réanimation il faut certes
délit il faut certes de l'équipement
mais il faut surtout des hommes et des
femmes compétentes pour s'occuper des
patients ainsi dix médecins
anesthésistes réanimateurs de la région
paca et dix médecins d'auvergne rhône
alpes seront très prochainement déplacer
vers les régions les plus en tension ile
de france et grand test
ces régions seront également renforcés
en infirmiers et en interne expérimenté
en réanimation
les régions occitanes idées nouvelles
aquitaine s'apprête à déplacer chacune
50 infirmiers et interne pour leur
prêter main forte
parallèlement la région paca et la
région auvergne rhône-alpes mettront
bientôt à leur disposition 100
infirmiers et internes
au total c'est donc 320 soignants qui se
prépare au départ dans les prochaines
heures et les prochains jours pour
épauler nos régions les plus durement
touchées par cette épidémie
je tiens vraiment à remercier le
personnel soignant pour les immenses
efforts fournis il donne un magnifique
exemple de notre capacité d'adaptation
collective il faut je crois à les saluer
collectivement pour cela et les
encourager à poursuivre ces pratiques
totalement inédite et magnifique de
solidarité enfin je sais que le
confinement pèse pour nombre d'entre
vous je rappelle qu'il ne doit pas être
un obstacle aux soins c'est pourquoi
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs nous
avons une attention toute particulière
pour les personnes les plus isolées et
notamment les personnes qui vivent en
situation de handicap et personnes âgées
les personnes fragiles les personnes
malades à domicile et donc je vous
encourage toutes et tous à continuer à
participer à toutes les opérations de
solidarité sur l'ensemble du territoire
et surtout les opérations de solidarité
de proximité
je vous remercie une question de l'usiné
nouvelle vous avez évoqué hier mobiliser
les industriels pour la production de
produits anesthésiants
comment et pourriez vous demander des
reconversions de lignes industrielles
est passé que des commandes d'état à
l'étranger comme pour les masques par
exemple alors nous suivons avec beaucoup
d'attention les tensions sur un certain
nombre de produits
il faut savoir et les français l'ont
bien compris que l'épidémie touche
l'ensemble des pays du monde
cette épidémie a les mêmes conséquences
en france en europe aux etats unis c'est
à dire que healy a énormément de
patients qui ont besoin de soins de
réanimation de soins lourds d'équipement
mais aussi de médicaments et donc nous
sommes très attentifs à l'accès à ces
médicaments ceux des deux des besoins
qui ont explosé en termes de volume tout
le monde a besoin de ces médicaments en
même temps et donc il ya des démarches
évidemment
entreprise depuis plusieurs jours en
particulier pour assurer cette filière
d'accès un certain nombre de médicaments
de réanimation un certain nombre de
médicaments d'anesthésié et il ya des
médicaments qui sont fabriqués en france
des médicaments qui sont fabriqués en
europe et donc nous travaillons en amont
au maximum pour sécuriser ces filières
et en aval et c'est aussi une belle
opération de solidarité au sein des
établissements de santé pour s'assurer
du stock de chaque établissement de
santé et là encore il ya des opérations
de partage à l'établissement qui a
quelques jours d'avancé sur son stock et
quitte à un établissement de chirurgie
qui a des médicaments anesthésiants et
le médicament de réanimation et qui ne
les utilise pas en ce moment parce qu'il
n'ya pas de chirurgie les prêtes à
l'établissement qui en a le plus besoin
ça se fait en intra régional ça se fait
en interrégional et nous sommes tous
attentifs aussi au niveau européen à
pouvoir fournir sur la durée ces
médicaments indispensables à la prise en
charge en réanimation
l' agence de presse médicale pose la
question suivante dans les services de
réanimation at-on une idée de la
proportion de patients qu'ovide plus qui
guérissent alors c'est une question
difficile puisque comme vous le voyez
l'épidémie s'étend depuis quelques
semaines on a chaque jour davantage de
patients qui entrent en réanimation
peut-être aujourd'hui un nombre qui
s'est stabilisé par rapport à hier mais
il faut être extrêmement prudent
ce sont des camps des quantités
absolument considérables sont des
nombres bon c'est les nombres de ne
disent rien et c'est ça qui me frappe ce
soir quand on vous dit qu'il ya 400
patients en réanimation vous imaginez ce
que ça signifie pour les équipes pour
les hôpitaux pour les équipes qui les
prennent en charge ces décès sont
plusieurs admission par service et donc
c'est à chaque fois de dépassements dont
on doit s'occuper
la durée de séjour en réanimation est
longue je voulais d'il ya plusieurs
présentations clinique certains ont une
détresse respiratoire isolé d'autres ont
plusieurs détresse associés cardiaques
rénales et donc plus la situation est
compliquée plus la durée de séjour
s'allonge et donc les réanimateurs les
équipes de réanimation font tout pour
sauver les malades pour les faire sortir
pas forcément directement à domicile
mais passer d'une réanimation
un service de rééducation est donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore cette
statistique de savoir comment comment
évoluent les malades
heureusement de plus en plus de mal
sorte de réanimation et on a des signaux
enfin un petit peu d'espoir de certaines
réanimation n'est plus touchées du grand
s ils disent que enfin des patients
sortent de réanimation donc la pression
commence à un tout petit peu a baissé
dans quelques rares hôpitaux du grand
test
ce n'est pas encore du tout le cas de
l'île de france qui a été touchée plus
tard que la zone grant s est donc on
aura là encore les deux ou trois
semaines de prise en charge de ces
patients les plus lourds avant de
pouvoir les transférer vers d'autres
services vers de la réadaptation
notamment donc cette cette durée moyenne
de séjour dépend énormément de la
situation du patient de son âge de la
présence de facteurs de risque et de son
tableau initial ou de son évolution
pendant le séjour en réanimation et à
chaque fois le pronostic dépend du
patient donc c'est très difficile de
faire des statistiques sur des patients
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir les uns
entre les uns avec les autres
hospimedia pose deux questions à l'heure
la première est ce que des difficultés
économiques ont été identifiés dans le
secteur du service à domicile est est-ce
qu'il est prévu des mesures spécifiques
pour soutenir ce secteur ça c'est la
première question d'hospimedia je n'ai
pas ce que je n'ai pas ces informations
elles sont essentiellement gérés par les
acteurs du secteur avec lesquels nous
discutons évidemment et en particulier
la direction générale de la cohésion
sociale et donc je me renseignerai pour
pouvoir vous donner la réponse eux au
plus vite et la seconde c'est le besoin
hebdomadaire de masques est passé de 24
à 40 millions ce chiffre sera t'il
encore réévalué du fait de l'importation
de nouveaux masques alors la
consommation et les paliers à
l'importation ce qui est très important
c'est que les français se rendent compte
nous sommes ce soir avec plus de malades
en réanimation que la france ne
comportait deux lits de réanimation il
ya encore deux mois
c'est une situation totalement inédite
totalement historique qui montre bien
l'impact impressionnant du virus et de
la l1
de cette épidémie c'est justement parce
que nous avons 800 établissements
concernés par le cos vide que nous avons
l'essentiel des dodos capacité de
réanimation dédiée à la prise en charge
des malades est plus grave que la les
pratiques hospitalières ont complètement
changé aujourd'hui vous avez des
patients qu'aux vide qui arrive aux
urgences des patients qu'aux vide qui
sont en médecine vous avez des
captations coville qui sont hospitalisés
au bloc opératoire dans les salles de
réveil non des salles de soins intensifs
dans des salles de soins continus dans
des réanimations et donc les soignants
se sont adaptés leur consommation en
masque est lié à la présence de tous ces
malades qu'ovide plus de plus de 20000
comme je voulais dit dans l'est dans les
établissements de santé et donc la
consommation de masse est importante en
france elle est très importante elle est
beaucoup plus importante que lors d'une
d'une journée habituelle en 2019 ou au
début 2000 20 et donc nous nous adaptons
c'est pourquoi nous avons faire priorité
aux importations priorité aux
productions françaises et donc
l'objectif est effectivement de pouvoir
répondre en permanence à la demande des
soignants ce que je vous rappelle les
soignants sont prioritaires pour l'accès
aux masques de protection puisqu'ils
doivent gérer au mieux les patients qui
sont notamment hospitalisés
une question pour rtl est-ce que le pic
est atteint dans le grand est et en ile
de france
et quelles sont les régions qui peuvent
s'attendre un prochaine afflux de
patients alors c'est vous savez la
prévision dans les épidémies elle est
très très difficile
et puis il ya un autre élément
heureusement très positif c'est la mise
en place du confinement
le pic on ne sait qu'il est atteint et
c'est valable pour toutes les épidémies
que venteux la courbe commence à baisser
on le voit chaque année pour la grippe
pour la gastro entérite pour
l'éventualité personne ne sait
exactement quand survient le pic
on sent que le nombre d'admissions
commence à légèrement fléchir dans le
grand est
si ça se confirme ce sera une très bonne
nouvelle mais il y a un autre aspect qui
est important c'est que le confinement
est efficace s'il ya moins de contacts
moins de personnes contaminées - deux
cas et donc moins de personnes
hospitalisées en réanimation
et comme le confinement et national il
ya des régions où on ne voit pas
énormément de cas arrivée à l'hôpital
c'est le cas des régions en particulier
du sud de la france et c'est grâce à
cette situation que les hôpitaux du sud
de la france nous aide à la fois en
envoyant des renforts humains et c'est
totalement inédit mais aussi en
acceptant vous l'avez vu des transferts
de patients très grave et donc c'est
pour ce pour cette situation française
totalement inédite du fait du
confinement aussi personne ne sait
aujourd'hui prédire et ce serait
vraiment très proches représentent que 2
de prévoir quelque chose
comment va évoluer cette épidémie
personne ne le sait dans le monde entier
les chinois aujourd'hui se pose beaucoup
de questions sur l'évolution éventuelle
la réapparition éventuelle du virus sur
leur territoire
c'est le cas aussi à hong kong où ils
sont actuellement en alerte pour une
deuxième bague donc on voit bien que
finalement on ce virus nouveau qui se
répand sur la planète continuera à
circuler potentiellement par vagues
d'après les spécialistes tant que nous
n'aurons pas une immunité collective
c'est à dire que nous n'aurons pas
suffisamment de personnes immunisées
pour l'empêcher de passer ou que nous
n'aurons pas d'autres d'autres armes
contre lui qui seraient des molécules
spécifiques efficace ou un vaccin est
donc toutes les réflexions actuellement
sont focalisés sur l'évolution de ce
virus
son comportement l'efficacité des
mesures barrières l'efficacité de la
distanciation sociale et surtout
d'efficacité du confinement qui commence
à se voir en italie en espagne pour
laquelle je vous rappelle nous aurons
une démarche d'évaluation à la fin de la
semaine pour voir si le confinement qui
est en place depuis maintenant pile deux
semaines strictement en france a un
impact ou pas sur l'évolution des
admissions et donc c'est une réflexion
internationale c'est une question
mondiale que de savoir ce qui se passera
lorsque les différents mécanismes de
confinement seront levés progressivement
prémunissent et s'est exprimé ce soir
sur ce sujet on voit bien que de toute
façon les comportements vont
profondément changer
et que après cette épidémie dans les
prochaines semaines nous aurons encore à
appliquer les mesures barrières à être
attentifs au lavage des mains à être
attentifs en particulier aux distances à
éviter un certain nombre de
comportements que nous avions avant au
moins durant cette période de quelques
mois où nous n'avons pas encore de
garantie non seulement sur la communité
collective mais aussi sur l'accès à un
vaccin
une question pour veiller les médias
face aux difficultés de mobiliser des
personnels soignants supplémentaires en
ile-de-france et en goûtant grand test
notamment serait-il envisageable de
faire appel à des soignants européens
allemands par exemple pour aider les
soignants français alors des difficultés
je les relativise il ya une magnifique
mobilisation si vous allez dans les
établissements de santé du grand-est
d'île de france
tout le monde est sur le pont donc
attention peut-être bien rappeler aux
français que nos professionnels de santé
sont totalement mobilisés il y à un
effort considérable de tous les
soignants
ceux qui ne travaillent pas en ce moment
ceux qui avaient d'autres activités ceux
qui sont retraités ceux qui sont
étudiants ceux qui ont un établissement
qui ne fonctionne pas parce que c'était
un établissement de chirurgie et qu' il
se porte volontaire pour travailler en
anesthésie ou en réanimation il y à des
transferts interrégionaux de personnel
le soignant je vous ai parlé de cette
mobilisation de plusieurs centaines de
médecins et d'infirmiers pour porter
secours aux régions les plus touchées
après la collaboration internationale
est plus compliqué pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que comme vous le savez
toute l'europe est touchée
la grande bretagne l'italie l'espagne
l'allemagne même si l'allemagne d'un peu
encore dans une phase croissante de
l'épidémie peut être à quelques jours
derrière la france il ya déjà cette
mobilisation de l'ensemble des soignants
pour gérer les malades de leur propre
pays et puis il ya quand même un sujet
importante quand on parle de
collaboration internationale c'est
l'accès à la langue et on sait bien
aussi que pour échanger entre
infirmières pour échanger entre eux
médecin voire même tout simplement pour
expliquer la situation à malade il est
plus il est plus facile d'avoir sa
propre langue natale
et d'échanger directement mais nous
avons déjà une très très très belle
collaboration européenne je vous ai
montré le nombre de patients qui sont
accueillis dans nos pays d'enhaut zen
dans le pays amis frontaliers ou parfois
même pas frontalier puisque nous avons
l'autriche aussi qui a conquis
accueillir des patients donc voyez que
là encore il ya une solidarité
européenne qui ceux qui s'expriment dans
un sens comme dans un autre parce que ce
qu'il faut aussi dire c'est que la
france qui est actuellement et des
aidera aussi des pays lorsque nous
aurons moins de cas et que les pays
seront potentiellement plus touchés que
nous on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une dans une nouvelle période de
solidarité que chacun essaye d'aider
qu'il ya des des prêts de matériel que
chacun essaie de trouver des solutions
au sein de cet espace européen et que
nous avons tous les mêmes questions
les espagnols les italiens les français
les allemands les britanniques se posent
tous la même question sur le devenir de
ce virus sur les meilleures façons de
lutter contre ce virus
une question pour sciences à venir qui
se charge de la production des tests
sérologiques en france et quand ces
tests seront ils disponibles pour un
dépistage à grande échelle alors les
tests sérologiques qui cherchent des
anticorps on est dans la recherche et
développement et on est dans la pratique
classique des industriels
toute une industrie du texte qu'elle
soit française européenne ou
internationale est donc aujourd'hui
toutes les entreprises qui font du test
qu'elle soit des petites entreprises de
biotech ou des grosses entreprises du
test sont en train de développer des
tests
donc il n'ya pas de deux filières
spécifiques on est attentif évidemment à
la production française de la production
européenne
mais c'est une grande compétition
internationale pour être capable de
mettre rapidement sur le marché ces
tests et comme je vous le dit
régulièrement il ya un enjeu de
fiabilité est-ce que ce test est
sensible spécifique disponible facile et
ensuite la question sera est-ce qu'il
est accessible en grande quantité
puisque évidemment il sera important de
tester assez vite un certain nombre de
personnes qui voudront savoir si oui ou
non ils ont été exposés au virus et si
oui ou non ils sont immunisés et la
question sera la même sur l'ensemble de
la planète
une première question pour france info
le premier ministre vient de dire à
l'assemblée nationale que le
déconfinement sera sans doute progressif
et évoque un déconfinement par classe
d'âge qu'est ce que cela veut dire
alors on l'a dit depuis le début
finalement si vous vous remémorez ce que
nous avions dit au début de cette
épidémie
il reste avéré que les personnes
fragiles les personnes atteintes de
pathologies chroniques diabétiques
insuffisants rénaux immunodéprimés et
les personnes âgées sont plus à risque
de faire des infections graves
c'est pourquoi je vous rappelle les
avions protéger très vite nous avions
protéger des ehpad
nous avions demandé aux personnes de
plus de 70 ans de rester confinés à
domicile donc cette démarche de
protection de prévention est toujours
valable
ce que le premier ministre nous dit très
bien c'est que non seulement nous sommes
devant une phase inédite de préparation
parce qu'il y aura un jour 1d
confinement de préparation du contenu
déconfinement la vraie question c'est
comment doit se passer ce déconfinement
quelles seraient les régions concernées
qu'elles seraient les tasses de
population concernée est ce que c'est un
des continents progressif est ce qu'on
continue à demander des mesures de
protection donc toutes ces questions
doivent être tranchés par des experts
bien entendu si elles sont très
complexes
quels sont les indicateurs qui
permettent de dire si oui ou non on peut
lever de confinement quelles seraient
les personnes qui prendrait le moins de
risques à être des confiné est ce que
ces personnes continueraient à appliquer
des mesures barrières au des mesures de
dissension sociale tous ces sujets sont
extrêmement complexes ils doivent être
traités dans les prochaines semaines et
on voit qu'il n'ya pas de solution
miracle et que ces questions les anglais
les espagnols les italiens côté de nous
se les posent aussi toujours france info
sur la levée du confinement
le conseil scientifique devaient se
réunir cette semaine pour rédiger un
avis sur la stratégie de déconfinement
quand cet avis sera t'il public alors le
procès scientifique est totalement
indépendant et il continue ses travaux
autant qu'il le veut en général il
publie ses travaux quand tu es quand ils
sont terminés donc je n'ai pas la date
de publication
je voudrais juste partager avec vous
deux éléments
nous sommes pile à deux semaines de
confinement aujourd'hui du confinement
strict puisque vous rappelez il mardi
on a eu jusqu'à midi pour pour être
confiné il ya eu des déplacements et
donc une demi journée c'est un peu
compliqué pour évaluer l'impact mais à
partir du mercredi toute la france
étaient concernés par le confinement
donc nous sommes exactement à deux
semaines de confinement strict et la
première étape et c'est peut-être la
plus importante c'est d'évaluer l'impact
de ce confinement nous pourrons le faire
dans les deux ou trois prochains jours
pour voir si après une semaine
d'incubation après une semaine
d'évolution on voit - arrivée de cas
graves en réanimation c'est vraiment
l'objectif que nous avons pour les
prochains jours
première étape cette évaluation de du
confinement deuxième étape et ce je vous
rappelle l'objectif du confinement
s'était pas d'enfermer les gens chez eux
c'était de réduire considérablement les
contacts pour éviter au maximum des
morts pour éviter au maximum des cas
graves pour sauver des vies et donc pour
soulager le système de santé qui est
aujourd'hui extrêmement sous tension et
et c'est important notamment en
réanimation et je voulais dit il ya
aujourd'hui plus de patients pris en
charge en réanimation qu'il n'y avait il
ya quelques semaines de capacité de
réanimation en france c'est vous dire
l'importance de cette épidémie est donc
ça c'est la deuxième étape
à partir de quand on verra arriver une
décrue n'est pas sur les plus graves et
une diminution de pression sur les
équipes de réanimation et ensuite
viendra le temps de la réflexion sur la
stratégie de déconfinement qui va être
de toute façon basé sur des situations
très complexes totalement inédite
personne n'a jamais des confiné en
période d'épidémie qu'aucun pays n'a
vraiment d'expérience même les chinois
on voit bien tâtonne savoir si leur
démarque complètement s'il redémarre
doucement si le redémarre par région
comment ils protègent au mieux les zones
qui ont été les moins touchés c'est
quelque chose de très complexe et donc
nous aurons besoin de mobiliser des
experts de réfléchir tous ensemble et
d'être proposé des étapes les français
je crois ont parfaitement compris qu'on
ne des confinerait pas de façon brutale
et nationales du jour au lendemain avec
d'un seul coup
l'art le retour à tous les comportements
d'avant puisque nous serons forcément
dans un objectif de protection des
personnes les plus vulnérables des
personnes fragiles des personnes âgées
est aussi d'informations maximale de nos
concitoyens sur la situation
la façon d'éviter de d'être affecté la
façon dont nous allons surveiller la
circulation éventuelle du virus donc il
ya énormément de questions qui seront
posées aux experts à ce sera une
décision mûrement réfléchie mais on m'a
pesé
c'était la dernière question maroc
locaux